he was a music video director for
meatloaf oh nice which is amazing
because if you watch meatloafs I'll do
anything for love it looks exactly like
Transformers like exactly same lenses
same shots it's exactly like
Transformers
why is Michael Bay a controversial
filmmaker or is he not is that a fallacy
I think Michael Bay becomes
controversial
well today I think there's multiple
reasons I think Michael Bay
personifies a character that likes hot
cars and hot women and a lifestyle that
is is slowly becoming more and more
uncouth
and today's modern audience
um
and so I feel like that was a very
consistent MTV generation
type of program my advice Miami Vice and
he lives in South Beach in Miami so I
feel like that's one element of it I
think that a lot of filmmakers
have this idea that they are artists and
artists are not allowed to have money
and artists are not allowed to be
successful
whereas
there's this whole idea of selling out
people like oh you're they're selling
out it's like well how are they selling
out well now they're they're making all
this money and I'm like as an artist if
I could make my art get it to more
people and be incredibly Financial
successful I would 100 want to do that
like I don't believe in the whole
element of selling out
you have a job you know these things are
jobs even as a director you still have a
job you have a boss you're going to have
a boss no matter what it's the studio
it's an executive producer it's a
financier and you have to do what that
boss wants or you're going to get fired
now they hire you for your creativity
and to bring what you have to the table
but it's still a job and I think a lot
of people don't really understand that
I'd say a filmmakers like Michael Bay
who's one of the most successful
Financial filmmakers of all time I mean
his movies made billions of dollars and
you may like his movie or you may not
like his movie I mean he's made movies
that I don't like he's made a lot of
ways that I do like but the fact that
he's a commercial filmmaker shouldn't be
a negative to him like what's why why
would someone not like that a person can
make movies and make a lot of money and
make a lot of people happy I mean
there's fans of his all over the world
so it's always kind of confusing to me
where well this filmmaker's not a true
artist because he makes too much money
or his movie scripts aren't as good and
it's like okay well
you can have that argument you know
those movies aren't for you but you can
go over and watch your Richard
Linkletter movie and and probably enjoy
that a lot more which is totally fine
like there are a lot of coexist because
if movies didn't make money there would
be no movie business you wouldn't be
able to make anything and it's not like
Sundance winners are making billions of
dollars at the box office I mean they
make those movies to win Awards they
don't make them to make a lot of money
and that's okay that's totally fine
there's a balance between that studios
are like these are our money makers and
they finance the award winners and then
everybody gets everything
and that's a pretty simple concept to me
so I don't understand why so many people
have such a problem with it or lambast
Michael Bay because of that
um
now granted not every movie he makes is
amazing I mean that I don't think any
filmmaker has made every single movie I
mean even Spielberg has had movies that
did not do well
or were not received well
so I mean
I don't think you can really completely
count out a filmmaker because of that
you know it seems like in every uh
industry you know writing art music
there's always one or two that get
branded as a sellout or like let's take
Nickelback I don't see anything wrong
with their songs I mean
but there was for a while they were just
attack or Bridges of Madison County or
or Banks here there's just different
people that they get this this label
that oh well this is not true whatever
right and
I it's it's really interesting how that
then the mob the The Hive swarms over
there and attacks and says okay this is
a sellout this is what a sellout but is
it really if people if people are voting
with their dollars and they're they're
voting for their dollars of Michael Bay
movies
what's wrong with that you just don't go
see them right and I mean they would
fail miserably if no one went to see
them and
granted now he's doing a lot more
streaming films because those studios
are offering him the same amount of
money to make streaming films and we
just did Netflix film and an Amazon film
and so
um that's fine like and those audiences
will enjoy it and his audiences that
don't watch his movies won't and it's
fine totally fine
it's it's the whole sellout thing is
weird to me because I don't understand
why being financially successful makes
you any less of an artist
I get that the idea like well you come
in and the studio is like well you got
to do all these things or we're not
going to hire you and you're like okay
I'll do those things oh well you're a
sellout it's like well
what do you mean like I'm doing a job
it's all a job you still have a boss
that pays you to do a job and if you do
a bad job they don't hire you back they
are somebody else because there's a
million other reviews out there that are
willing to do the job so it's kind of
confusing
the fact that the art versus business
you know it's a show business
not just a show and so I think that
these Studios have it built where it's
like they can make enough money to do
the smaller pictures that will make
Awards and play Sundays and things like
that but there's a balance across the
board
and that's okay like as long as people
understand that's all right like you're
allowed to make whatever you want
it might not make Michael Bay money and
you might not never make a movie again
but
that's okay like everyone's allowed to
like whatever they want that's that's
all allowed I think and the audience is
the boss in a lot of ways too so you
think that Michael Bay's movies you say
might represent something in this
current age
where
what it's it's too much of sort of the
the 80s 90s beautiful lifestyle that
maybe now we're rebelling against
here but
I mean things are definitely across the
board being more scrutinized uh and as
they should I mean like I'm 100 on board
with me too I'm 100 bored with all of
these movements to make the industry
cleaner and better and more inclusive
I'm totally on board with that
absolutely and so I feel like some of
those elements that have carried over
that used to be consistent
are changing and and probably should
change you know we talk about horror
movies and we have 80s cliches I don't
think every movie should be an 80s
cliche I think that that's silly and
lazy at some point you know you want we
have modern times that we have modern
cliches we can easily utilize so it
doesn't have to be about that
but I think he
he has a very specific brand that he
produces and creates and if that brand
is incredibly successful they're going
to keep making that brand but you have
filmmakers like Lars von Trier who has a
very specific brand as well
and that Brand's not for me
I mean his movies are way more
exploitive than anything Michael Bay has
ever done
but he's an artist he's not because he's
not making billions of dollars
and that's a very interesting discussion
as far as people that are like well
Michael Bay's not an artist but large
volunteer is an artist and it's like but
he's more exploitive and he's less
exploitive but he's making more money
my bottom line is you're allowed to like
whatever you want and I don't care it
doesn't affect me at all and um I'm not
going to go be like oh well you liked
hereditary so I'm not going to talk to
you again like you're what your voice
doesn't count because you liked this
movie I didn't like it's like I don't
care you're allowed like whatever you
want
sure and you hope more people would
think that
and some people like to look at pretty
people and fast cars and and and want to
Envision themselves in that lifestyle
yeah and and that's a very consistent
brand that's been sure done for decades
I mean there's a lot of I don't know if
people are aware but there's a lot of
movie stars that are attractive sure I
mean that's not a new thing and not
saying every movie has to have all
Perfect movie stars in it and they don't
most of them don't
but
I don't know it's it's it's
a constant discussion of what's the line
and especially nowadays with the
internet and social media and
back in the day it was like oh you look
at this magazine cover like we shouldn't
put a track to people on magazine covers
because it makes people feel bad and now
it's like oh we're on Instagram and this
this influencer who's half dressed has
five million followers and so I need to
do that if I want to be famous I have to
do this and get an only fans or get a
patreon and do all these things and like
that's what the kids nowadays are
dealing with
it's like you're stuck in this giant
mass of a billion people all vying for
attention at the same time to the
internet
and any way they possibly can and I have
friends that make hundreds of thousands
of dollars on only fans and that's great
like if you can do that and you're
satisfied it's it's making your living
that's awesome like good for you I don't
care again I'm not the police of anyone
else's happiness
if you do something that makes you happy
as long as it's legal
that's fine like that's great because I
wouldn't want you coming to my house and
being like oh you like to play video
games well that's ridiculous you
shouldn't do that you can't do that you
shouldn't play video games it's like why
why can't I play video games what does
this affect you it doesn't affect you at
all and so it's always a confusing
argument to me because yeah no one
should be the sheriff of someone else's
happiness
do you remember the TV show solid gold
from the 80s okay so it was just like a
music it was almost like a with Dick
Clark with the with the um oh but it was
with very risque dancers and Andy Gibb
and they would introduce you know it was
almost like a Casey Kasem top 10 but
they had the dancers come out right sort
of and and
yeah it was it was quite you know these
were like Vegas showgirl style dancers
which you know and then you would have
you know quarter flash or whatever the
80s band was that was right but you know
I mean
there's a reason people like to look at
certain things and yeah it's just
interesting
um I mean Baywatch was on the air for
how many years sure sure
right right
um and I mean the industry's always kind
of been about that you get some very
charismatic people and I mean there are
very charismatic people that
are not necessarily what people would
call you know incredibly attractive I
guess but there's we have fantastic
Comedians and actors all across the
Spectrum now of things literally across
the Spectrum and that's fantastic I mean
the more inclusion the better I totally
agree with everyone should get the
ability to find their own happiness well
and what constitutes eye candy is is
very I mean there's just there's very
different levels totally so um but I
guess that's a negative term now so we
can't use that I didn't say it okay I
did
I don't want to get canceled no sorry
sorry I said eye candy do you have
arguments with any of your friends about
Michael Bay movies
Michael Bay is going to haunt me forever
um
I don't think I have arguments with
friends over Michael Bay
and it's not like I'm a um I don't have
like a shrine to Michael Bay in my house
it's a very small Shrine okay uh but I
just put an offering every day for him
when I would try to get into Film School
it was like it was a problem that I
wanted to be a commercial director to
make movies that made money I knew that
horror movies and action movies made
money and I wanted to make movies that
first off could appeal to a global
audience and make as much money as
possible because you learn very quickly
if you make money in movies you get to
keep making movies sure
so
by not getting into Film School it was
basically like well that's you're not
the kind of filmmaker that we want we
don't want any more filmmakers like you
you're wrong and it's like I don't
really think I'm wrong I think I'm just
different
and I think it's confusing that nobody
wants to make money in a business that
you make money with
so the Michael Bay argument
and like oh and I'll speak my piece
about Michael Bay where I'm like I don't
I don't understand someone not wanting
to make money in movies if you don't
want to make money in movies that's very
easy and your job is going to be really
easy because it's really hard to make
money in movies so you're gonna have a
great time
um
but I don't get I get into it at film
festivals more so like or around I have
there's people that I call filmis I've
always called filmis since college that
are like well you know I only go to
these types of theaters and I only watch
these types of movies and if the movie
cost over 30 million dollars I won't
watch it because I can't support that
kind of blow I'm like I don't care like
you can watch whatever you want it
doesn't affect me like at all
but it's strange when people don't like
they have this argument that he should
not be included as a Storyteller or as a
filmmaker when some of the stuff he's
done I mean his action things and the
stunts and what he's pulled off are
absolutely incredible and he's got some
of the best stunt teams in the world and
he's really well involved with the
military and gets access to all of this
stuff that nobody else gets access to
because he respects those elements
Scripts you know he's not as worried
about because there's plenty of
explosions so you're happy with the
explosions he's made some movies that I
love he's made some that I don't so I
mean it's not like I argue about it that
much but I'm always confused because if
I could be Michael Bay and make whatever
I want at a massive budgetary scale
that'd be amazing like I would love to
do that because who doesn't want
unlimited power and control over their
story so he's earned that by doing what
he does and he's got a very specific
brand and I appreciate that and there's
lots of directors that have that same
ability you know Tim Burton has a very
distinct brand
It's JJ Abrams has a very distinct brand
like they they are getting well known
for what they do Kevin Smith and a lot
of very successful directors do what
they do best and that makes a lot of
money for them
and I don't think just because someone's
making more money or making the things
you don't like or you don't respect that
they shouldn't have a seat at the table
uh at all I think that's ridiculous